bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 3 février en autriche après
beaucoup d'hésitations la prestation de
serment du gouvernement conservateur
extrême droite aura lieu demain le
président de la république autrichienne
aux avoir étudié le programme ce
gouvernement leur a fait signer un texte
sur la démocratie
patrons et syndicalistes ensemble pour
réfléchir à une refondation sociale que
le medef appelle de ses voeux en
conduisant les discussions manifestation
au pluriel d'agents et personnels
hospitaliers en france martine aubry
promet des moyens pour les besoins
immédiats des hôpitaux nous vous
montrerons que ces besoins sont
essentiels notamment dans les services
de gériatrie où il y à des lits vides
faute de personnel
quarante huit heures avant leur premier
match du tournoi des six nations les
joueurs de l'équipe de france de rugby
sont rassemblés à cardiff au pays de
galles sous la férule de leur entraîneur
bernard laporte bernard laporte sera en
direct et en duplex de cardiff avec nous
dans quelques minutes il y as an
naissait jacques prévert le poète
populaire le plus vendu du siec celui
qui inventa le jeu du cadavre exquis
nous avons sa mémoire et son actualité
sans doute la pression est elle très
forte sur le président de la république
d'autriche monsieur thomass costil
pressions internationales et européennes
en particulier pressions intérieures et
populaire puisqu'il y avait hier soir
quinze mille personnes dans les rues de
vienne tout cela pour protester contre
l'entrée dans le gouvernement d'autriche
de représentants des partis dits libéral
mais en réalité d'extrême droite le
président classe thil a fait durer le
plaisir tout au long de cette journée
après avoir tout non seulement des
conservateurs mais de jörg haider
lui-même qu'il signe une sorte de charte
démocratique où il est question de la
responsabilité de l'autriche dans les
crimes monstrueux du nazisme
finalement la présidence annoncée il ya
quelques minutes que la prestation de
serment du gouvernement d'extrême droite
conservateur se ferait demain une
journée politique donc intense à vienne
dont nos envoyés spéciaux patrice en
d'année gilles jacquet nous faut
maintenant le récit ont peut-être écrit
des hommes est néanmoins leur serrer la
main
ainsi le président clé style
qu'encadrent ici le conservateur chou
seul et le populiste haider pourra
l'instant historique et pour une fois le
mot n'est pas galvaudé
les deux candidats au pouvoir viennent
en effet de signer un document où il est
stipulé qu'il reconnaisse la
responsabilité de l'autriche dans les
crimes commis par le national socialisme
le texte contient par ailleurs à
plaidoyer pour les droits de l'homme et
il doit figurer en préambule au
programme commun des conservateurs et de
l'extrême droite pour que le président
leur confie le pouvoir
mais ce feu vert les deux hommes
l'attend toujours lorsqu'il se présente
cet après midi devant la presse pour une
conférence qui se veut alors celle du
couronnement et qui tourne à la farce
ils n'ont alors rien à annoncer
sinon qu'ils attendent et attendent
toujours
haider qui s'est mis l'europe à dos
comprend alors qu'il lui faudra avaler
encore quelques couleuvres servi par
clay style avant de gouverner
monsieur rider le président n'a toujours
pas dit oui une réaction il finira par
dire oui et le plus vite possible
alors en attendant tout seul et haider
passe le temps par exemple il médiatise
la signature de leur accord histoire de
dire nous sommes prêts nous sommes en
phase à la fraîche quelques 2000
personnes manifestent en agitant des
trousseaux de clés en allemand clé se
dit schlussel la moquerie glisse bien
sûr mais ce chou seul l'homme qui donne
les clefs du pouvoir à l'extrême droite
plus la foule se masse aux abords du
palais présidentiel
car elle sait que là haut haider échoue
seul son revenu mendier leur pouvoir un
président qui s'emploie à temporiser
mais qui au final devra céder
patrice homme donne fin du suspense dans
tout sera consommé demain avec la
prestation de serment
effectivement claude bien entendu on l'a
remarqué depuis 48 heures le président
tu les styles a fait le maximum pour
temporiser
je crois qu'on peut dire qu'il a fait
pour des raisons diplomatiques et pour
des raisons personnelles les raisons
diplomatiques c'est qu'il a voulu
montrer à l'europe qu'il faisait son
possible mais qu'il était coincé
ainsi le veulent les résultats du
scrutin d'octobre dernier
et puis des raisons personnelles parce
que c'est un authentique démocrate et
lov voulu obtenir un maximum de
garanties avant de donner la clé du
pouvoir à la coalition des conservateurs
et de l'extrême droite et en ce sens le
préambule dont il est question au début
du reportage que vous venez de voir un
tel acte fort dont on dit ici qu'il est
vraiment historique alors les prochaines
étapes et bien ce sera bien entendu la
prestation de serment demain matin et la
formation du gouvernement
on s'est bien entendu que les
conservateurs revendique le poste de
chancelier
l'extrême droite aura sans doute la vis
chancellerie et laura parité oblige cinq
ministères qui sont on le sait
maintenant la justice la défense les
finances les affaires sociales et
l'équipement et c'est ainsi que
l'autriche tournera la page sur 30 ans
de social démocratie
merci patrice dans les sondages réalisés
en autriche la cote de popularité de
jörg haider est à la hausse bien au delà
des 27
% de suffrages qui l'a recueilli aux
dernières élections et que dire de sa
popularité dans sa province de carinthie
dont il est le gouverneur depuis le mois
de mars 99 en consignes et patrick
desmulie n'ont constaté lagen fourtet le
fief électoral de jorg haider
c'est ici qu'il est gouverneur et c'est
avec passion qu'on nous parlait de lui
ce matin au marché en particulier
lorsqu'il fut question de savoir si
monsieur ryder avait ou non des
sympathies encombrant pour le troisième
reich
c'était clair il était même pas nés à
aider à cette époque ce sont les
socialistes qui parlent tout le temps ce
sont eux qui ramènent toujours cette
affaire dit claire sur les tapis il faut
les écarter ces socialistes à dire de
leur dire d'aller voir en israël ce
qu'il fait l'israélien avec ces
prisonniers chaque fois que haider a
tenu des propos contestables c'était
parce que ces propos étaient sortis de
leur contexte et monter en épingle
sian rider le populiste fait un tabac
ici en carinthie
c'est peut-être parce que c'est la plus
pauvre des neuf régions autrichiennes
peut-être aussi parce que la carinthie
est frontalière de la slovénie une
minorité cela va vite encore ici
aujourd'hui avec ces écoles bilingues
slovène allemand leur présence a
tendance à renforcer le patriotisme
autrichien d'écart 1 tient à
l'université de klagenfurt les jeunes
n'ont pas tous voté haider mais cet
après midi il accepte l entrée de son
parti au gouvernement
haider ce n'est pas mon ami mais je
crois que nous n'avons pas d'autre choix
même s'il ne laissera droite ou pour le
classe à l'extrême droite
les 41 opposé à rider estiment en
général que la démocratie autrichienne
est suffisamment solide pour supporter
sans faiblir l'entrée au gouvernement
d'un parti populiste
si la presse russe critiques et
pressions internationales sur l'autriche
comme contre-productive vous déplacer de
son côté le parlement européen demande
et après un vote à la commission et au
conseil des ministres de l'union
européenne de se tenir prêts suspendre
les droits européenne l'autriche veut
pour l'instant pas de sanctions même si
l'europe risquent ainsi de fonctionner
au ralenti le processus en cours en
irlande du nord semble s'arrêter le
gouvernement britannique vient de dire
qu'il s'apprêtait à suspendre les
pouvoirs de l'exécutif biconfessionnel
nord-irlandais c'est le problème de la
non remise des armes par l'ira qui est à
l'origine de cette décision
et puis à gaza en territoires autonomes
palestiniens et direct sur la frontière
après deux heures de discussions la
rencontre entre eux et ehud barak et le
président yasser arafat a échoué de part
et d'autre on a constaté les accords
aussi bien sur le prochain retrait
israélien en cisjordanie que sur les
modalités de conclusion de règlement de
paix final
officiellement pourtant on ne veut pas
parler de crise et puis ce soir
la direction palestinienne annonce qu'un
état palestinien indépendant avec
jérusalem pour capitale sera proclamée
au plus tard en septembre prochain
ce sont les patrons français qui avait
pris l'initiative désireux de quitter
des organismes paritaires d'ici la fin
de l'année s'il n'était pas réformée
libyen il avait invité les syndicats
pour une rencontre et des discussions
sur ce qu'ils appellent la refondation
sociale dirigeants syndicaux et
patronaux où était donc cet après midi
au conseil économique et social pour une
rencontre sympathique décontractée et
enthousiaste en tout cas c'est ainsi que
la voyais ernest antoine seillière le
patron du medef
reportage nathalie noise ans et patrick
voix à l'origine de la rencontre le
medef qui tente de s'imposer en maître
du jeu étant des premiers arrivés pour
les caméras l'optimisme de circonstance
alors que l'on en andreu disperser les
syndicats font leur rentrée avec un mot
d'ordre commun ne pas laisser le
patronat imposer seul son calendrier et
ses priorités pour la refondation
sociale qu'il appelle de ses voeux
il est vrai que le match a commencé fort
et que l'équipe du medef fait monter
assez fort le pensive en début de partie
et va durer un an la partie eh bien on
va j'étais un peu de pressing aussi en
haut du terrain en espérant que l'une
des deux équipes ira vers le but
peut-être la nôtre pourquoi pas ce soit
aussi bien à droite un an de discussions
qui démarrent dans la confusion
à peine arrivée marc blondel de lons la
pression imposée par le medef le
patronat menaçant nous quitter les
organisations paritaires
si les discussions qui s'engage
aujourd'hui devait échouer négocier ses
conditions
ils sont ils ont défini une pression
c'est pour eux la pression ils vont pas
blague nous la crotte forme et l'a
transféré pour que ce soit nous qui
subissons à chaque fois qu'on va
demander quelque chose de gros face à
face d'important c'est la première fois
depuis cinq ans que syndicats et
patronat se retrouvent autour d'une même
table mais la rencontre d'aujourd'hui
n'est qu'une première étape
très vite les partenaires sociaux vont
devoir se retrouver pour discuter cette
fois sur le fond
ce soir les cinq organisations
syndicales et les mettaient se sont mis
d'accord sur huit chantiers prioritaires
parmi lesquelles l'assurance chômage la
santé au travail et la formation
professionnelle le grand chantier social
voulu par le medef est lancée alors
gérard leclerc quand on parle de
refondation sociale autour de cette
table parce qu'on joue le même jeu pour
dire ce que disait de ne peut être pas
et permettez moi et deux à deux jours du
tournoi des six nations
mais le père faure rugbystique oui la
refondation sociale ça ressemble un peu
aux savait ce qu'on appelle les
chandelles c'est à dire ceux ce
balmanais voix voilà qu'on envoie très
haut dans le ciel centrale bien savoir
où il va rebondir qui va le rattraper
qui sera trompé par les faux rebonds
bref sur quoi tout ça va déboucher eh
bien là c'est le patronat qui a donné le
coup de pied c'est lui qui mène le jeu
hier il était défait par les 35 heures
eh bien il a su imposer son calendrier
est pour une large part les peines d'un
vaste débat sur l'assurance chômage les
retraites et le dialogue social dans
l'entreprise
et puis paradoxe c'est le
site même de grandes négociations dont
il ne voulait plus en entendre parler il
ya seulement deux ans alors dans cette
partie dans ce big bang social les
syndicats sont obligés de jouer mais
avec le handicap de leur division
et puis souvent sur le terrain du
patronat qui pousse ses thèses libérales
comme les fonds de pension les nouveaux
contrats de travail ou bien la
représentativité réelle des syndicats
dans se retrouve où il a encore un jeu a
joué lui aussi d'écouter il risque de se
retrouver sinon hors jeu ce serait
réaliste du moins limitée dans son
action volontariste si non
interventionnistes comme sur les 35
heures ou la sécurité sociale mais il ya
une marge en réalité entre le medef qui
refuse toute immixtion de l'état la cfdt
qui imaginent une articulation entre les
accords sociaux
et puis la loi et puis force ouvrière où
la cgt pour qui la loi doit rester la
référence
alors pour conclure disons que tout le
monde y gagnerait à ce que l'on re
définissent des règles plus claires en
matière de concertation de paritarisme
et puis souhaitant pour rubio comme au
rugby pour y revenir que le jeu de la
négociation sociale lancée aujourd'hui
puissent se développer que des points
soit marqué et tout cela débouche sur un
nouveau modèle social disons à la
française merci beaucoup
il y avait plusieurs milliers de
personnes dans les rues en fin de
matinée à paris pour protester contre le
manque de moyens des hôpitaux le
personnel hospitalier de la région
parisienne réclament des budgets des
effectifs au service des besoins en
évoquant la situation des services
d'urgence mais aussi toute la difficulté
de leurs conditions de travail
martine aubry a promis qu'elle
accorderait des moyens financiers
supplémentaires pour répondre à des
besoins immédiats
elle a ouvert hier une série
d'entretiens avec les fédérations
d'agents hospitaliers
ceux ci attendent de voir la réalité des
promesses alors dans l'immédiat
voyons-nous ce qui fait défaut dans un
service de gériatrie c'est à l'hôpital
de la pitié salpêtrière à paris
des lits sont vides faute de personnel
pour s'occuper des personnes âgées
malades actuellement dans le service
il y à 38 passion est souvent une seule
infirmière et pourtant cet hôpital ne
fait pas partie des plus mal loties
juliette bout et julien trias ont suivi
cette seule infirmière ce matin là entre
la prise de son service à 7 heures
jusqu'à 15 heures
une fois de plus ce matin anne
l'infirmière se retrouve seul pour
distribuer 38 lots de médicaments
une fois de plus ce matin fabrice l'aide
soignant mène les patients les uns après
les autres dans l'unique douche du
service une fois de plus il va falloir
parer au plus pressé
anne enchaîne ses soins de plus en plus
techniques sur ces malades grabataire
chaque jour plus dépendants
ce matin de prises de sang des soins de
routine
et pourtant entre la tension quotidienne
et l'accumulation de fatigue
les nerfs sont à vif les malfaçons poser
enfin là et les jours fériés
on voit récupérer jours fériés et un
agent à voir deux voire trois ans
pendant les repas le personnel est
mobilisé
très peu de patients sont indépendants
aussi les aides soignants doivent
répéter inlassablement les mêmes gestes
quand la charge de travail est trop
lourd ce qui est le cas en ce moment
parce qu'on a des difficultés en
personnel j'ai une recrudescence des
accidents de travail parce qu'elles ne
prennent plus les précautions et se
servent pas forcément des appareils pour
manutentionner les malades elles sont
tellement pressés qu'en fait
c'est en deux
mouscron problème ici la moitié des lits
sont inoccupés mais faute d'effectifs
suffisants
le service refuse 25 nouveaux patients
chaque semaine alors que déjà le temps
manque
je vais être obligé de faire des choix
de choisir des soins de je n'aurai plus
le contact
comme je voudrais avec le malade je ne
pourrai pas aller prendre dix minutes
pour faire un soin fera que je prenne
cinq minutes je pourrai pas aller
prendre une pause je pourrais pas être
disponibles comme je le voudrais une
course contre la montre qu'elle
reprendra demain matin une fois de plus
dans les retards et il y avait aussi
d'autres manifestants aujourd'hui
c'étaient des agents des finances venus
dénoncer la réforme engagée par le
ministre christian sautter
les sept fédérations syndicales estiment
que cette réforme menace l'emploi et
qu'en resserrant les réseaux des impôts
et du trésor sous prétexte d'une
meilleure efficacité
en fait on diminue les postes de travail
il faut rappeler que les finances
emploie actuellement 180 mille personnes
une rencontre entre ministres et
syndicats est annoncée pour le jeudi 10
février 500 millions de francs
supplémentaires pour faire face aux
difficultés rencontrées par les
forestiers privés tempêtes des 26 et 27
décembre dernier il s'agit du surcoût
généré par le transport du bois et
lionel jospin qui est intervenu sur le
sujet à l'assemblée nationale a détaillé
un plan national pour la forêt ou
d'autres dispositions fiscales sont
envisagées pour les professionnels du
bois
le premier ministre a également évoqué
la marée noire en parlant d'une
exceptionnelle réactivité de son
gouvernement et en précisant que la
cargaison du pétrolier erika était bien
du fioul lourd numéro deux et non un
déchets hautement concept cancérigènes
et puis ajoute j'ajoute qu'un album cd
est mis en vente au bénéfice de la ligue
de protection des oiseaux
plusieurs artistes dont yves duteil
laurent voulzy gibert i go i go frais
ont accepté d'offrir gracieusement une
de leurs oeuvres
le produit de la vente de cet album
permettra de soigner quelques-uns des
trois cent mille oiseaux touchés par la
marée noire de l'erika un premier
ministre qui a tout lieu d'être content
puisqu'il est largement soutenue en
corse selon un sondage louis harris paru
dans le mensuel corsica près de trois
corps sur cap lui font tout à fait
confiance ou plutôt confiance pour
améliorer la situation pour l'instant
en corse on parle on parle beaucoup lors
de tables rondes de réunion de rencontre
où tous les acteurs non de politique de
la corse s'exprime depuis les pêcheurs
les animateurs culturels jusqu'aux
responsables associatifs en lutte contre
les phénomènes de drogue selon nos
envoyés spéciaux arnaud bouteille vient
cas c'est un peu toute la société civile
de lille qui semble se réveiller
depuis dix jours il parle sans retenue
les acteurs de la société civile
dressent leurs constats et proposent
leurs solutions pour sortir de la crise
de la culture à l'environnement on
aborde ici tous les domaines mais ce
n'est pas tout les gens ont peur d'un
développement qui se ferait sans enjeux
d'un développement qu'espéré à leur
détriment
ok en tout cas se ferait sur des modèles
qui ne serait pas la leur et qu'ils ne
leur conviendrait pas un peu comme si si
les gens avaient peur de perdre leur âme
dans la bagarre mais lors des
consultations personne n'évoque les mots
autonomie indépendance
les corses veulent du concret exemple le
problème de la drogue dans certains
quartiers le phénomène devient très
inquiétant félix bonardi est venu tirer
la sonnette d'alarmé à l'assemblée
territoriale
mais ce n'est pas facile et on se
retrouve avec un problème qu'on n'arrive
pas à gérer
alors est ce la pudeur s l'orgueil est
ce qu'on veut pas en parler est ce qu'il
faut en parler je pense qu'il faut en
parler il faut que tout le monde en
parle
autre lieu autre priorité françois
dominique chi est maire d'un village ce
qu'il souhaite avant tout c'est la
réforme de la carte administrative
supprimer les départements pour
simplifier la décentralisation et on a
l'impression en tout cas c'est mon
sentiment depuis toujours qu'il ya une
espèce de décentralisation retenue je
vais vous à dire quelquefois muselé et
que les administrations sont très
farouchement attachés à leurs
prérogatives et alors pour voir et ça ça
vous bloque sa douche est en tout cas
fortement avec cette parole libérée les
corps se répète que sur l'île un espoir
est né il ne doit pas disparaître dans
l'hebdomadaire le point à paraître
samedi madame erignac la veuve du préfet
a battu à ajaccio le 6 février 81,18 se
dit profondément meurtri par la
rencontre entre lionel jospin des élus
nationalistes corses
qui ont justifié les violences près
d'aix-en-provence à vauvenargues le
député des bouches du rhône guy teissier
député démocratie libérale a été
sérieusement blessé la nuit dernière par
plusieurs hommes armés son état jugé
sérieux mais ses jours ne sont pas en
danger
comparution devant la cour d'appel de
paris de vincent bardet de son épouse
yasmine a accusé d' esclavagisme moderne
il avait employé sans la payer dans des
conditions contraires à la dignité
humaine selon la justice
une jeune femme togolaise la voici âgée
de 17 ans à l'époque l'avocat général de
la cour d'appel a requis un an de prison
dont 5 mois ferme et 200 mille francs
d'amendé à l'encontre des époux bardet
décision le 20 avril une décision qui
fera certainement jurisprudence selon
olivier caroff qui assistait à
l'audience aux états unis à san
francisco ce tir la conférence mondiale
sur les rétrovirus et les infections
opportunistes le participantes
évidemment évoqué le sida et l'épidémie
telle qu'elle continue de se développer
dans le monde notamment dans les pays du
sud
ils ont également abordé les
modifications de comportement à l'égard
du sida on a tendance à moins se
protéger c'est ce que jean daniel
flaysakier a constaté dans le quartier
de castro c'est à san francisco là où il
y a vingt ans les premiers signes du
fléau sont apparus
sur le panneau de l'arrêt de bus une
publicité pour un médicament du sida ici
personne n'est surpris on est dans
castro à san francisco le plus célèbre
quartier homosexuels au monde dans les
années 80 le sida emporté une grande
partie de la génération des 35 50 ans
celle à laquelle appartient jimmy
séropositif depuis 15 ans gym y avait
beaucoup de ses amis mourir
la chorale dans laquelle il chante a
perdu près de 200 de ses membres alors
aujourd'hui quand de jeunes gays
oublient les règles élémentaires de
prudence ils se sentent obligés
d'intervenir quand quelqu'un que je
connais joue avec le feu lui dit
d'accord cet avis mais écoute un peu par
où je suis passé mais avec rayons vécu
aussi l'épidémie du sida dès son début à
san francisco pour eux les progrès liés
aux traitements ont paradoxalement
entraîné aujourd'hui les comportements
de plus en plus risqué surtout chez les
plus jeunes
il y a des gens qui font comme s'il n'y
avait plus rien à craindre
pourtant le sida tue encore elle même si
c'est moins souvent qu'avant ça veut
dire j'ai été sage jusque là revient
pour une fois c'est un peu la garde un
peu en profiter c'est là qu'on se met
vraiment en danger
la communauté gay de castro sait qu'elle
doit rester très vigilante pour empêcher
le sida de revenir jeté une ombre
tragique sur les clichés qui symbolise
san francisco jean daniel flaysakier ce
qui caractérise les discussions à san
francisco c'est qu'on constate que non
seulement ces repères mais qu'on ne voit
pas la fin de ce fléau et oui claude
homme est fait ici il ya certes des
nouvelles importantes par exemple on
sait que la combinaison de traitement ce
qu'on appelle la trithérapie continue à
faire diminuer la mortalité mais on voit
aussi apparaître des inconvénients des
effets secondaires de plus en plus
puissants de ces médicaments et on sait
qu'on ne pourra pas les utiliser d
utiliser pendant des dizaines d'années
parce que les inconvénients commence à
être vraiment vraiment très important
alors on attend l'arrivée de nouveaux
produits il ya un médicament qui devrait
empêcher le virus d'entrer dans la
cellule et d'y déposer son programme
génétique que la cellule reproduire des
milliards d'exemplaires chaque jour
mais ce produit est encore en évaluation
et ce n'est malheureusement pas demain
qu'ils seraient sur le marché encore en
ce qui concerne les vaccins même
problème plus personne ici ne croit au
vaccin préventif dans les prochaines
années
on imagine plutôt des vaccins
thérapeutiques c'était des vaccins qui
concernerait seulement les personnes
contaminées et qui viendraient en
quelque sorte en apport des traitements
mais surtout la grande crainte c'est de
voir les comportements à risque
reprendre peut-être parce qu'il ya une
fausse sécurité données par les
trithérapies peut-être aussi parce qu'il
est lassitude je vous donne est juste un
exemple pour conclure il ya une et
ulissi qui a été fait sur des gens qui
viennent chercher une trithérapie du
lendemain en quelque sorte les gens qui
ont eu des rapports probablement risqué
et qui ne sont pas protégés et bien 40%
des personnes qui sont venues chercher
ce traitement savait pertinemment 40%
savaient que leurs partenaires étaient
porteurs du virus
et ça c'est très inquiétant et ça veut
dire qu'il faut que les messages de
prévention et d'éducation continue de
plus belle parce que malheureusement
comme vous l'avez dit on n'est pas du
tout au bout de cette épidémie
merci jean mas miel il a fallu y visite
du président indonésien en france et en
europe monsieur durand man wade venu
chercher un soutien européen pour
rappeler que les conflits dans son pays
était loin d'être terminée que l'on
compte par centaines le nombre de morts
entre ethnies ou rebelles séparatistes
dans les différentes îles qui composent
l'état indonésien commentaires jean-marc
il use
il est le premier président indonésien
élu démocratiquement
il est pratiquement aveugle et se
déplace avec difficulté mais si
aujourd'hui abdurrahman wahid
intellectuels musulmans très populaire
reçoit le soutien de l'europe et des
états unis
c'est que 200 millions d'indonésiens
compte sur son courage et sa sagesse
pour éviter le pire
le pire c'est d'abord le risque d'un
conflit ouvert avec cet homme le général
oui rente aux ex chef d'état major de la
dictature est toujours l'homme fort
d'une armée puissante est intouchable
le président wade lui a demandé de
quitter ses fonctions pour répondre
devant la justice des atrocités commises
avec la complicité de son armée l'année
dernière au timor-oriental le général
n'a pas obéi mais le président wade
persiste et signe
du jamais vu en indonésie je suis en
mesure de tenir le pays tout entier
je n'ai aucun ennemi personnel quels
qu'ils soient
quant aux conflits ethniques et
religieux
nous procéderons par petite famille à
des foyers de tension dispersés sur 5000
kilomètres d'un bout à l'autre d'un
archipel stratégique imbibé de pétrole
ou truffé de minerai après la sécession
du timor
c'est le petit l'archipel des moluques
qui s'embrase les rivalités entre
chrétiens et musulmans ont fait 1700
morts en un an
l'armée soupçonnée d'avoir versé de
l'huile sur le feu
plus grave encore pour l'avenir d'une
indonésie économiquement exsangue la
révolte nationaliste de sa province la
plus riche
hachey à la frontière malaisienne
réservoirs de pétrole
convoité par une petite minorité
islamistes ici les atrocités de l'armée
ne date pas d'hier
les négociations seront longues en
octobre dernier le président wade avait
été l'élu d'un compromis boiteux
il vient de recevoir l'appui du
président du parlement mais son bras de
fer avec le général louis ranto pourrait
refaire descendre dans la rue
les groupuscules islamistes en
tchétchénie la capitale grozny est
presque entièrement sous le contrôle des
forces russes on extermine les foyers de
résistance on nettoie la ville
expliquent dans leur jargon les
militaires russes en s'installant tandis
que des civils eux sortent de leur trou
commentaires jérôme baugnies le silence
dans ce qui reste de la capitale
tchétchène première journée sans
bombardements depuis le début de
l'offensive russe en septembre dernier
les forces de moscou semble plus
décontracté leurs officiers affirment
que la ville a été vidée des combattants
tchétchènes qui aurait subi de lourdes
pertes les civils du centre des grosses
ni sorte enfin des caves où ils sont
restés terrés paralysés par la peur
pendant quatre mois sur la porte une
inscription ici on vit comme pour
marquer l'espace réservé aux civils
sortez moi de là un plan cette
survivante en les mois n'importe qui
mais sortez moi de là les soldats russes
prétendent contrôler et enfin les ruines
de la capitale rebelle pourtant ils ont
tort après 18 heures de tirer sans
sommation sur tout ce qui bouge sur le
territoire tchétchène il y a toujours un
otage français depuis plus de quatre
mois brice fleutiaux photographe
indépendant est détenu le ministre
hubert védrine est ce soir à moscou où
il doit rencontrer demain le président
par intérim vladimir poutine
il doit évoquer le cas de brice
fleutiaux
en espagne près de séville un grand
magasin meubles s'est effondré il y
aurait 100 61 blessés à l'origine de cet
effondrement une énorme bousculade de
consommateurs venus bénéficier des
soldes commentaires jacques cardoze on
seront peut-être déçus un rayon soldes
et c'est le drame
à l'ouverture des portes de ce magasin
de meubles ce matin ils étaient 200 sans
le savoir ils vont provoquer leur propre
chute
une immense bousculade les conduit au
premier étage la foule excessive se
pressent autour des meubles soldés mais
le plancher ne peut résister c'est la
rupture d'une poutre métallique qui a
provoqué la chute des clients 3 mètres
50 plus bas dans une sorte d'effet
toboggan par chance personne ne se
trouvait au rez-de-chaussée
je courais lorsque j'ai entendu un gros
boum c'était terrible il y avait des
gens sous les décombres
et puis très vite les secours sont
arrivés je me trouve juste à côté de moi
j'ai vu l'immeuble a déjà présenté de
graves défauts de structure en 1993 son
constructeur avait alors été condamné
par la justice
le président de la région annonce
l'ouverture d'une information judiciaire
afin de déterminer les causes de cet
accident
l'événement sportif de la fin de cette
semaine ce sera samedi après midi en
direct sur france 2 le premier match de
l'équipe de france de rugby pour le
tournoi des six nations ce sera face au
pays de galles à cardiff avec un nouvel
entraîneur bernard laporte nous
retrouvons dans quelques minutes
bernard laporte c'est un homme à la
forte personnalité un homme de coups de
gueule qui trace sa route
christophe duchiron et laurent chemla
l'ont accompagné
paris boulevard périphérique janvier
2000 la porte de champerret la porte
d'orléans la porte de la villette et la
porte bernard avec ses petites lunettes
enfants de gaillac et du tarn provincial
monté un jour à la capitale avec tout
son temps et toute son ambition
en 1991 comme demi de mêlée et capitaine
il est champion de france avec bègles
bordeaux en 1998 comme entraîneur il est
champion de france avec le stade
français
certes tous les entraîneurs de rugby
sont passionnés mais chez la porte soit
plus que chez les autres
c'est vrai qu'après les passionnés mais
quelque part on a souvent si et par vaux
moi je souffre aussi
et donc il ya effectivement certains mal
de mon ex est excessif naturellement
devine derrière derrière ce mot passion
la porte les joueurs du quinze de france
ceux qui ne le connaissaient pas en vite
compris que ce grand sentimental
mènerait ses hommes sans faire de
sentiments donc nous en question la vie
qu'est ce que la vie
olivier l'équipe du stade français que
bernard laporte a sorti de l'anonymat
pour l'amener au sommet du championnat
de france
c'est ce club qui l'a fait roi laporte
n'a que 35 ans il n'a jamais été
international et pourtant on pourrait
dire que il est trop jeune pour
entraîner à ces mots là où qui a passé
l'expérience je pense que si s'est donné
les moyens de
d'accueil toutes les compétences qu'il a
aujourd'hui et qui lui sont reconnus et
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui travaille
énormément et qui s'investit énormément
dans tout ce qui fait à gaillac où il
porta ses premiers maillots de rugby où
il revient régulièrement en passant par
le café rabhi jouer à ce genre de belote
du troisième type qui est le paulinia la
faute aux murs ses amis qui trinquent
la passion selon saint bernard je sais
quand vous pensez que l'ami de rentrer
sur le terrain parce qu'ils aiment la
perfection c'est un énorme tube qui a
tout donné aux commissions morue beenie
man un jury me david et il ne veut ni la
solitude ni le silence
bernard laporte se fait dans l'affectif
les explications doma hommes et les
coups de gueule en passant par la porte
de la muette on se disait le pire qui
puisse lui arriver
une extinction de voix
on se faire bernard laporte bonsoir
dans quel état d'esprit êtes-vous c'est
un état d'esprit très combatif 13
offensifs vous êtes prudent assez
décontracté je crois que l'on va jouer
un match de rugby et je voulais
m'assurer vie c'est avant tout un
plaisir ont de plus nous avons un double
challenge puisque effectivement une
équipe de france ces dix champions du
monde
donc elle va être attendus par ces
gallois est par contre l'équipe de
france a perdu les deux dernières fois
qu'elle a rencontré les gallois donc
c'est assez paradoxal est pour le moment
l'équipe de france n'a pas trop de
pression je crois qu'il ne faut pas 100
m se mettre de pression supplémentaire
l'événement a lui-même sera une pression
importante de le jour du match
à prix égal aux idées terminée mais
passer mes questions pression vous vous
servez là m quand même parce que keserü
chiron le rappelait les coups de gueule
vous avez presque un sens militaire dans
l'entraînement n'ont peut-être savez je
n'aime pas beaucoup parler de moi
peut-être que j'ai un sens militaire
c'est vrai que j'aime j'aime les choses
bien faites maintenant les gallois vont
nous rendre la tâche particulièrement
difficile donc il va falloir s'appliquer
je crois que le détail sera important
mais avant tout il y aura le combat
l'envi l'envi de les repousser l envie
de les empêcher de marquer je crois que
c'est surtout ça qui va être important
est que je vais essayer avec lui dit à
mes joueurs c'est chercher à avancer
sans arrêt est ce que à la différence de
ce que disait ville points qui étaient
pour une sorte de tactique d'évitement
vous vous êtes pour la technique
d'affrontements délibéré non pas du tout
je suis tout simplement pour m'adapter
aux conditions du rugby moderne
d'aujourd'hui
donc je dirais que les bonnes équipes
mais ça vous savez manier les deux les
deux avec perfection il faut savoir
affronter il faut savoir éviter aussi
mais pour éviter il faut d'abord être
capable d'affronter alors vous êtes un
spécialiste pratique des coups de gueule
mais alors là le règlement ne vous
permet plus d'être sur le terrain vous
êtes dans la tribune comment vous allez
faire comment va vous entendre
je sais pas se répéter moi je serais
peut être un peu malheureux mais bon je
ne sais pas je vais découvrir tout ça
j'aimais bien à peu près du terrain
avant un petit peu la sensation
d'exister auprès de mes joueurs
effectivement là dans la tribune et bien
je serai comme le commun des mortels
quelqu'un d' inutile mais vous savez un
entraîneur le jour de match c'est
souvent quelqu'un dimitile et les lan
pression on était au bord du terrain qui
est utile à laissez pas votre genre de
penser aux est inutile mais dites-moi
est-ce que vous avez une définition du
rugby version la porte parce qu'il
paraît que vous dormez que vous mangez
vous penser rugby fait que ça vous êtes
rugby totalement si vous avez une
définition justement de ce sport on la
définition je crois que c'est vrai que
c'est un sport c'est un sport de
passionnés c'est un sport d'abord qui
qui collectent un petit peu tous les
états d'esprit tous les physiques
puisque effectivement pour jouer au
rugby on peut être petit on peut être
grand on peut être gros peut-être
filiforme et puis on peut être maçon on
peut être ingénieur je crois que c'est
la diversité des gens qui font la
richesse de ce sport bon je crois que
c'est la grande définition du rugby elle
est là alors on dit aussi que vous avez
un look d'intellectuels c'est un peu
vrai y ait des petites lunettes
vous êtes un peu dégarni tous est ce que
vous sentez à l'aise dans ce milieu du
rugby ce que j'ai l'impression qu'ils
vous ont effectivement bien adopté
depuis que vous êtes le plus jeune
entraîneur l'équipe de france il serait
prétentieux de ma part de dire qu'ils
m'ont bien adoptés et je dirais que
depuis depuis quatre jours je prends
beaucoup de plaisir à entraîner cette
équipe j'ai rencontré des garçon
attachant des garçons passionnés des
garçons qui ont envie donc ça suffit à
mon bonheur et croyez moi je suis très
heureux et très satisfaits d'eux d'entre
elles aujourd'hui l'équipe de france je
prends beaucoup de plaisir depuis quatre
jours maintenant il va falloir entrer
dans le vif du sujet à l'affronter ces
gallois et j'espère avec beaucoup de
plaisir et beaucoup d'avis vous
n'envisagez pas du tout la défaite
vous savez quand on est sportif de haut
niveau on n'envisage jamais la défaite
on sait que le match sera difficile nous
savons que ce match sera très difficile
nous sommes attendus et à nous de
relever le relever le défi mais surtout
le drama dramatisons pas je crois que
l'événement n'a lui-même est assez
important donc consomme trop de nous ce
que nous avons à faire sur le terrain et
c'est déjà très important
merci beaucoup bien dans la porte et
bien on suivra tout ça ce sera sur
france 2
ce samedi après midi merci le 4 février
1900 il ya dans tout juste 100 ans à
neuilly-sur-seine naissait jacques
prévert beaucoup lui rende maintenant
hommage mais c'est facile puisqu'il est
le poète le plus populaire son recueil
parole s'est par exemple vendu à deux
millions deux cent mille exemplaires 400
établissements scolaires porte son nom
un vrai record bizarre vous avez dit
bizarre
avait-il écrit puisque c'était aussi un
dialoguiste et scénariste sans prévoir
cet engouement même si nous a laissé
beaucoup de feuilles poétique célèbre
richesses relève ici abdel moustafa
nathalie gallet évoque jacques prévert
jacques prévert le poète de la liberté
qu'à broche devenu adulte amoureux des
mots tendres avec les hommes il fait
partie comme peu d'écrivains de notre
mémoire
elle joue sous et nous ressent
toi tu m'aimes et jetez-vous
nous vivions libres et par les chanteurs
les plus grands montants grieco blue
jean jacques prévert a su écrire avec
simplicité des poèmes d'amour qui marque
le 20e siècle
rappelle-toi var avec brest
ben quoi ce jour là rappelle toi cela
barbara le mot veut pas si je te tutoie
je lis tu as tout ce que j'aime
même si je ne les ai vu qu'une seule
voix je vis tuer tous ceux qui s'aiment
même si je ne les connais pas mais ce
promeneur parmi les moues avait tous les
talents
les marcel carné dont il fut le
scénariste lui doit beaucoup
notamment pour ce classique des
classiques comme vous voulez
alors à la rampe par frédéric non
abandonner comme ça mais c'est tout seul
sur le boulevard du crime
dites moi quand je vous reverrai bientôt
peut-être sait-on jamais avec lazard
paris grand jour par les pompiers pour
ceux qui s'aiment comme au vannes oc à
six classes et les collèges les plus
grands créateurs sont ses amis et
particulièrement picasso le peintre
admirait le sens des couleurs de prévert
dans ses collages une manière picturale
presque enfantine pour exprimer ses
rêves ses admirations ses désirs ses
cauchemars et son célèbre
anticléricalisme prévert sans jamais se
prendre au sérieux
fecamp paix la poésie dans la rue
génération après génération on aime lui
renvoyer l'hommage mais le 4 février
2000 c'est mort centenaire et je suis
sûr que nous le passeront tous ensemble
un peu quand même
alors vous avez vu des extraits de
l'exposition de collage de roger pic
mais aussi vous signalez vous
recommander brigitte fossey catherine
arditi qui propose un spectacle prévert
c'est au théâtre molière à paris il y à
celui ci c'est un coffret france inter
de textes de prévert pour les s'entend
donc justement et puis le livre d'yves
courrière 7 aux éditions gallimard une
biographie de jacques prévert
le voici voilà nous arrivons à la fin de
ce journal jours à venir rappelle
l'activité concernant l'autriche la
prestation de serment entre le du
gouvernement conservateur extrême droite
avec le chouchen qu'on voit ici monsieur
yang leader aura lieu demain
finalement le président arbitre monsieur
thomas clay style que vous voyez à
accepter que ce gouvernance face après
beaucoup d'hésitations et après leur
avoir fait signer un texte sur la
démocratie engageant ce gouvernement qui
prêtera donc serment demain la météo
c'est avec sophie davant dans quelques
instants suivi du point route de valérie
maurice à 20h50 envoyé spécial basé rue
heures 35 florence duprat vous
présentera le dernier journal et puis
demain c'est au 54e vérité gérard morin
recevra ernest antoine seillière le
président du medef à 13h vous
retrouverez carole gaessler et rachid
arhab et puis bien sûr à 20h béatrice
schönberg alain dit bonsoir merci